we're going to hear now from ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky addressing
anti-war demonstrators wishing each
other good health
but from recently this
soldier greeting this army greeting is
something that ordinary people starting
to use in their day-to-day language when
greeting each other because we are
protecting
our country from russian invasion from
the russian attack we are protecting our
homes in our land from the full-fledged
and out
russian war and russian aggression
some of us are military servicemen
serving our country in the army others
are serving as doctors with scalpels and
in their hands doing the surgical
operations
either are working to protect
the children and their families and this
is our heart this is the heart of
ukraine
standing together against the evil.
i have three minutes of my address to
you
[Music]
and this first minute i would like to
dedicate to the minute of silence to
those who have
fallen
uh in the fight for their country to our
soldiers uh to those who served in the
fire crews those
who are
working as
pilots those who are making heroic deeds
in
different areas protecting their country
and have given their lives away for this
let us
let us commemorate
their souls and
rest in peace
my second minute i would like to
dedicate to the commemoration of
our
citizens of our civil
uh population those people adults and
children
dozens and hundreds of them who have
died without knowing so sacrificing
their lives for the independence of our
country
let us commemorate them with silence
and this third minute i would like to
dedicate to you to the people of europe
i would like to call upon you not to be
silent i would like you to come out on
the streets and support ukraine support
our efforts and support our fight
because if ukraine will not stand europe
will not stand
if we will fall
you will fall so please don't be silent
do not turn the blind eye on this come
out and support ukraine as much as you
can
i have felt the name
be and if we win and i'm sure we win
this will be the victory for the whole
democratic world this will be the
victory
of our freedom this will be the victory
of
light over darkness
of freedom over slavery and if we win we
will become as blossoming as europe and
europe will be flourishing
more than ever after this magnificent
victory glory to ukraine slavo queen
vilnius frankfort
bratislava braga
parish
questions
ukraine
frankfurt prague bratislava leon paris
uh belissi
vilnius all of you today are ukrainians
and thank you for this
so the cheering that you heard there
from uh live crowds in those cities that
the president of ukraine mentioned that
dw reporter akansha saxena is in
frankfurt uh one of the cities mentioned
where anti-war protesters have gathered
to hear that address from vladimir
welcome talk us through what we've just
uh witnessed and
the ukrainian president's main points
[Applause]
the people are still behind me clapping
to that address that ukrainian president
vladimir
zelinsky just made and it was a very
emotional speech he said that if you
stand if he he was addressing to all the
europeans and he said he said if you
stand for uh the values of democracy for
the values of brotherhood
if the ukraine will stand
only then the europe will stand and
those were similar words to what you've
heard earlier this week as well but
those were his main points he was trying
to rally support for him support for his
countrymen support for ukraine uh in
this hour of crisis and he expects that
europeans will
gather together and they will be behind
him in
the russia's you know against the
russia's war on his country so he was uh
talking about all those points he was
trying to gather support at the same
time he also observed
minutes of silence here for people who
have lost their lives for the ordinary
citizens who've lost their lives uh in
this hour of crisis and the war
and he also thanked his countrymen he
thanked the young people who are at the
front lines of this war in ukraine uh
and he was talking to the europeans to
also uh take a leap out of uh the
experiences of everyday ukrainians who
are going through uh this crisis and uh
to support them wholeheartedly against
the russian aggression
and clearly uh he was very well received
there
absolutely i mean people are still
cheering uh here and
it was an emotional appeal and it was
received as such
people here
are ordinary germans behind me who have
gathered after uh you know in the friday
evening after their work
and they have come here to listen to him
they came to uh to to
give support uh to the ukrainians a lot
of ukrainian citizens nationals are also
here and i was speaking to some of them
earlier and they told me that their
families behind in ukraine uh are living
under a lot of stress at this moment uh
and uh you know they are standing here
in hope that the europeans will actually
be standing with them in solidarity and
support them and also pave the way uh
somehow for uh ukraine uh to support
ukraine also in their bid to fast-track
their uh
their
membership in the block
all right thank you so much for that uh
account account saksana in frankfurt
city center
you